alors crise où la glace est entré à dans
ma vie quand j'étais tout petit et
c'était très émouvant mots parce que on
voit par des gens qui jouaient des reds
occupent dans notre pays nicolas
demorand
nan mais martin short
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je les attendrai calédonie oise qui
projettera l'embarras des filets your
app qui m'applaudissent saignante
construisent mais tan maï maï qui pose
une manière pour penser qu'il en coûte
15 euros
[Applaudissements]
chaque année je suis renversé de voir
que comme au canada
immense ils dorment lice durant la
période hivernale ils ne vivent vraiment
que colloque et c'est vraiment génial
quand il a tué les jeunes dès leur
réveil m enfilent leurs équipements du
jeu des patins jusque jusqu'aux épaules
est à 7 heures du matin ils sont prêts à
aller sur la patinoire tu t'habilles
[Musique]
williams-sonoma porte monnaie un thème
en charge on voit surtout des jeunes
porte et de l'équipement de seconde main
donc souvent ils vont avoir de
l'équipement brisé des bâtons avec les
lames fendu des gants tout troué
[Musique]
imaginables et du geste et nater rookie
quand cette année une alliance pékin
marque adnane page et 400 projets de la
ville mais des trombes d'eau puis kina
langue tu nous en avons une turbine sur
guette chaque année mark higgins à
suzhou chine toc est un goujat mitigé
story 4 c'est pour ça que je pense que
la prochaine étape dans dans le
développement de the hacker dans la
région c'est définitivement un
amphithéâtre fermé et réfrigérer
certains fonds était
administré à une organisation mais
malheureusement on voit beaucoup trop de
corruption pays
les fonds de la difficulté à se rendre
dans les bonnes mains c'est pour ça que
l'amphithéâtre est à moitié construit
pour l'instant
[Musique]